mix vous en connaissez donc la cancel
culture mais là ça va quand même assez
loin la très chic oxford faculté réputé
qui sort plutôt conservatrice a en tout
cas de l'extérieur qui attaque un
symbole quasi intouchable au royaume uni
la reine d'angleterre
ça vous a choqué oui d'autant que je
suis un ancien de ce collège en
particulier d'un côté ce n'est pas très
surprenant dans la mesure où les
universités toutes les universités sont
les universités sont souvent de gauche
ou au royaume uni et aujourd'hui c'est
plus vrai que jamais dans de ce point de
vue là ce n'est pas chaud en même temps
ces dix salles communes et les étudiants
ont parfaitement le droit de le de la
décorer comme ils veulent il ne s'agit
pas du décrochage d'un grand portrait
peint qui était suspendu là depuis des
années c'est une
c'est un portrait photographique acheté
en 2013
donc ce n'est pas grand chose mais en
même temps ce qui est choquant c'est que
la reine est le chef de l'état est aussi
le chef de l'église d'angleterre et le
collège comme da et l'université
d'oxford fait partie de l'église
d'angleterre et donc que qu'un petit
groupe d'étudiants décide que la n est
pas à sa place c'est vraiment très très
très chaud tôt et oui justement
justement j'investisse comment ont
révélé les britanniques parce que voilà
on vous dit les universitaires sont
souvent de gauche
mais qu'en pensent les anglais quand
même il aime pas trop en général qu'on
touche à la reine en tout cas pour la
plupart exactement exactement c'est
encore un symptôme
je dirais de ce set cet isolement des
intellectuels et des universitaires qui
habite une bulle c'est pareil d'une
grande partie du reste là de la
population qui les autres ne comprennent
pas et franchement ne tolère pas ses
agissements
on a vu des statuts au déboulonner
d'ubisoft
les noms de rues rebaptisé est ce que ce
mouvement vert notamment la reine un
petit prendre de l'ampleur vous pensé au
royaume uni avec ce phénomène de la can
cette culture qui nous vient des états
unis et qu'on voit aussi en france à
nous nourrir contre la reine
absolument pas en même temps déboulonner
les statues ça continue parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a eu une annonce de
150 professeurs de l'université d'oxford
qui veulent boycotter le collège d'oreo
sur la façade de ce collège
on voit une grande statue d'un
bienfaiteur de l'université le
colonialiste celle roads donc ça c'est
encore plus important que l'incident de
la supporte la reine hier mais ça montre
encore une fois que le monde
universitaire est un monde à part des
gens ordinaires n'y comprennent rien
merci beaucoup président du parti
conservateur britannique à paris d'avoir
été avec nous